what is going on everyone how's it going
happy Wednesday we are halfway through
the week we are still all working from
home and working hard as we can to bring
constant to you guys of course and yes
gamespot live is right here from my home
for the foreseeable future so I hope you
guys are ready to dive into some
resident evil 3 remake demo it is indeed
out in it New Zealand so I went on my
playstation and I made an account
registered as my region in New Zealand
and downloaded the demo so that's how
I'm playing today I heard if you're on
Xbox you could just change your region
to New Zealand and play it that way and
it's super easy so if you guys want to
try it out go ahead it's also gonna be
up tomorrow here if you don't want to go
through all of that hustle and you just
want to check it out
for now and then try it out yourself
tomorrow but yeah there's a few ways to
get around and download it and play for
yourself so we are going to hop right in
and check it out I have not and you know
obviously I have seen footage of this
game and videos and I've been really
excited because it looks good and I'm
ready to get scared and anybody who
knows me from fgc knows that I have
played a lot of Marvel 3 and I have
gotten body by nemesis in Marvel vs.
Capcom 3 so you know I'm pretty excited
to check it out um yeah this is gonna be
interesting it's gonna be fun I'm ready
to check it out let's hop right in just
let me know in the Chinese you can
actually hear the audio
having a little bit of issues for the
stream but I think we're good to go now
if you can hear the audio then awesome
all right looks like you guys are high
yeah the chalkboard I love my chalkboard
I like writing in what games are playing
every day so thank you cyborg man
already throwing out shout out to Wesker
I love me some west carry my little West
Cara figurine is that the office I
should have brought him home with me and
something we gonna be working from home
but yeah all right
let's let's do it let's hop right in
okay yeah
story mode experience the nightmare this
is the demo the final game may differ
you cannot save or load your game in
this demo all right I don't know how
long the demo is either but I did hear
that people have you know played this
already so let's find out let's do it
you can hear all right thank you Bob
Jones awesome mmm
greetings appraoch oh we're starting
looks like the sea train
it's Jeff yeah put some respect
I am you
my team was sent to rescue
most of the hundred thousand
my platoon has suffered serious losses
yeah
that's where we come in
the same thing
you know Carlos is Alicia's lock stone
so it's like okay
it's geared up head up to street level
right
all right how about now I turned up the
volume a bit
oh the classic the spray easy peasy
I turned the volume up bit forgive me
there is about a 30 second stream delay
between the chat and the stream so as
soon as I see your message I tried to
activate I turned up the volume like
almost half half way more so let me know
all right so got those people man I've
been stuck on a New York City subway
train for like three hours before
because of some craziness that happened
oh snap
Wow it's like Inception no change to the
volume all right hold up let me see so I
want to make sure you guys will be able
to hear this oh I think I know one
second
whoa I don't want a sentence cuz I don't
want it to mess up but just let me know
if this is helping at all I feel like
it's not changing much all right how
about now more up than this
the music is kind of low right now but
is it any higher than it just was
I don't want to waste any bullets to try
to test the sound but let's go
hello no we just started so you've made
it just in time right in the gray of
morning on September 25th I'll leave
this up and if you guys want to read it
you can just go ahead and hit that pods
if you're watching the bud
I'll read so we got that yeah yeah let
me get somewhere where there's actually
more noise copy that right we activate
the power definitely need all the what's
rattling up there
that's gunpowder and oh we can get from
here all right hold up real quick guys
so I'm gonna try to fix in volume one
sec
uh-oh oops wrong one there we go alright
this should be better
sounds louder on my end anyways alright
totally not creepy doll a little we
think I can get over here alright it
looks nice
and it looks pretty accurate in terms of
oh alright in terms of what a train
station looks like
all right how fast are they not that
fast I guess they can take a headshot
take to my Chuck's all right could we
use a charm only got nine bullets better
not want me to keep doing that
all right we're reactivating power but I
do want to take a look-see all right we
got a lot of dead bodies oh we got
backup oh wait hold up hold up wait hold
up man look at this face - I like these
graphics right now I have uh I have a
knife or something yet as he actually
did four bullets tank zombies
shoot the bobblehead is there something
special now let's go back let's go back
can I get back in here yeah but I'm
gonna waste my bullets oh I got some
bullets back for that all right cool
thank you guys thank you where's the NEM
this sounds better right awesome this
looks really good so far kind of make me
go down this creepy alleyway of course
oh wait give me that give me that
absolutely better about that
Oh dings Oh
Oh No stay oh you like got this weird
walk dude cut it out okay
oh all right let's get out of there then
ding
they're so tanky let's get out of here
already
all right noted
no D Carlos I've reached the main avenue
which way do I go
the aliens
accurate accurate alright you eat girls
insane
okay then I put this out by shooting
this fire - oh I wasted a bullet for
nothing
oh I'm gonna need to go find some sort
of a wrench all right oh of course
uh-uh
we got this
need to find a wrench of sorts I mean I
shouldn't try to waste my bullets right
now I feel like this is where I came
from right oh he got up again you can go
ahead and see oh my goodness wait how
can I use my knife
yeah there's my hey wait wait
okay oh that didn't work I was trying to
test out my knifing skills ah
no leave me alone can't can't get in
there
oh she's hurting man get a wrench from
down here that's you think you to try
and shoot should I get somewhere safe
and use my herbs it's really dark around
the roof feels a little safer maybe
maybe not
oh I see a little bauble that up there
again all right
let me let me try to heal shall I let's
see oh oh I haven't any Matt hey oh I
actually
word let's get some of that
alright now we're good again I broke it
I did it I broke the box there was
another one though oh I don't think I'm
in that area yes
I'll break that one too it's kind of
dark it's a little dark I just wanna
a little dark just gonna turn it up a
little bit more oops
save roll queen
that's a little better yeah all right
where's this wrench I think just when
I'm looking for me now Oh or denied it
totally go around cuz I'll be nice to
wait here ruckus no I didn't go around
it I went around the other way
sure beats what's up girl
how's it goin thanks for tuning in yes
because he's curious I made an account
that was registered in New Zealand and I
was able to download this because it's
out of there oh where can I go for this
what I assumed to be as a wrench I'm
looking for it to open the fire
extinguisher I did see the yellow boxes
this one the wrench isn't gonna be in
there though right just that gunpowder
hmm
I keep moving well at least and I can
use this now
oh there she woke up no supermarket chat
says supermarket let's go that's a big
one that's big zombies big zombies
oh there's yeah thank you
confirm use
no I hear them walking up on me slowly
didn't mean to shoot it I don't want to
waste a bullet on and whalen oh no just
fine a helicopter and fly away yeah
that's that sounds like more of a plan
actually all right so I'm gonna go back
over there in a sec but we need to lure
these zombies away from the area and I
don't want to leave I didn't want to
waste a bullet on it I feel like IRL
around no she's staggering now don't
want to waste a bullet on this
oh do they actually want me to okay i'll
spencie
what
okay Kent I don't think I can tease
leave me alone
wait hold up she's hurting right now I'm
still hurting right now
[Music]
easy all right let's do oh it was in the
safe room the whole time I kinda have to
go a little further back that's kiss the
one where I shot the first bobblehead
don't she do it won't work yes I I
realized that um wait see see if it's in
there you know if you can't be troubling
me like this guys if it's not in here
uh-huh Oh thought there might be
something in there for me let me get
this all there was the red one
darn um I don't see it in here just some
I know Akash we were definitely gonna
stream doom eternal today but uh we
found that a way to get our hands on the
demo so that's why we're playing this
since it but tomorrow we'll play some
doom tomorrow no I was hoping he wasn't
paying attention
leave me be all right
I did not see the wrench in there in the
safe room
is there another explosive barrel around
there's some Sparky sparks
unless it was on the roof I know there
was a zombie up there well cut it should
be into the pharmacy not the
supermarkets don't even go in there that
is a toy store moon Donuts women's
clothing I somehow made it around this
group last time on accident at least
they don't run because then I would
really be in trouble she'd the sprite
they sparked ding I should have did that
oh let's see if I gonna make it around
this hook Oh didn't work my too injured
to do my little there we go
I'll come back for those guys later
might be up here somewhere
get a doughnut that would be nice all
right that guy got up hmm
and I get this way I can go this way - I
didn't go this way yeah
oh snap oh
he's gonna wake up obviously right
I hear I hear oh my goodness okay okay
[Music]
nice so I think I need any house
I heard something in there ooh
everyone's getting rocks right now all
right
we're outside I could see a bag in there
somewhere that kind of looked like I
could open it let me just go try to take
oh this one this bag looks it looked
pretty pristine but all right I'm out
I'm out I'm out I'm out
I didn't see it in there
oh there's the pharmacy AE aureus I am
doing the right direction
no you goo rooms oh yes please
definitely need that
oh my goodness and well no we need the
wrench oh I'm so sorry Joe I'm like I
can't tell when there ever been just a
few extra times just for good measure oh
snap
this isn't realistic at all um all right
I'm keeping my eyes oh okay hi great gun
powder thank you let me
[Music]
ha I didn't even have the shotgun yet
this is no I need a green one I want to
put it's a green one and red ones but I
think Jill is kind of hurting right now
I'm on caution inside so let me just I
can't even use it oh no oh no I need I
shouldn t used all three of those green
ones earlier wait someone said the bolt
cutters were in the pharmacy yeah I do
need it
Derek okay it's on our one looking for
bolt cutters
don't don't see you
don't like it I've flipped on every
possible shut up let's keep it moving
oh go all right
close that door okay
huh
you know that worked out this must be
the subway company's offices all right
good to know
subway company's offices please where to
earth that nothing okay some donuts
there's you don't who do we get a donut
really yeah there we go
can't go over there here
No all right
[Music]
the safe combo was on the poster in the
pharmacy anything wow this is creepy
hose
and I like silent a grenade oh wait wait
wait
all right did you get it you bigoted no
I tried to dodge that one okay found the
room where the shotguns in I am hurt oh
my god crap
I made a huge mistake using those green
herbs earlier I have the need to find
more or oh man I'm in trouble I'm in
trouble now
all right let's let's let's go back a
little bit so it was on the poster and
here in the arms
oh boy call our helpline
there's so many posters in here
all right let's go back up here
person in here all right
someone said it was
oops oh no not like this alright will
this buy me time or is that zombie still
coming for me right now alright so the
safe combo in the under the 388 sign
alright cool
at least I know that screen bought me a
few seconds where is this guy okay okay
okay let's go back
nine one eight all right well I'm gonna
go pick up that water who's real quick
oh he was he was in the shadows working
and I was only half a century this guy
oh that
I'm like I can't tell if he's dead or
not
let's just so for the does alright give
me this darn water hose oh all right the
book cut is in that safe I am I really
going through all this safe to get these
bolt cutters or did I seriously miss out
on this bolt cutting sorry yeah I know
sorry about postponing doom but we'll be
playing in tomorrow for sure for sure
under the 388 no better stop trolling me
right now well I saw someone say it was
nine money so I'm gonna go with that and
hope for the best
or did you mean a different poster oh
snap
thank you fish
that moon oh there's a lot of people and
some rock music aha
they're jamming
oh there we go yay thank you fish this
is oh crap crap oh yes perfect that's
exactly what I needed that is exactly
what I need it because now I can stop
hearing my heartbeat ah yeah stand up
straight
it's good for your back cool feel a
little bit better you got that McCormick
on the show right there
all right let's go we're still a little
bit more prepared now he does
another box
okay oh no all right shoot
I just you I just oh there we go oh okay
I definitely want that shotgun
I'm gonna need to make some adjustments
to my inventory again I think Oh
nice eight Oh crud all right
[Music]
crap I don't want to use my my heels cuz
I mean I'm fine it says right there
fine let's see everyone wants the chill
sandwich for real they are chomping on
me
ding decisions decisions
I need a backpack or something alright
so how about I go connect the firehose
so and then come back to this that might
be the best course of action and all the
way back to the arrows on
this sounds like a scary option I'm not
gonna lie
let's go back to the safehouse
[Music]
oh there's stuff here then I missed the
first time because I was scared to walk
by this guy
[Music]
how useful is this grenade gonna be
should I just leave it in the I might
leave the grenade I might leave the good
name I'll store that yeah if I I don't
want to throw it and waste it
no way no way I saw I started the Dodge
but it got me anyways oh I'm gonna end
up my baby
how close that was even hitting them but
whatever
all right
you're equipped now I feel powerful
ix honey alright let's go do that to you
man she looks like Oh word she looking
at me looking at me sideways like that
one you're right that was satisfied for
good measure just one good time it's one
good time
nice looking looking more clear alright
so let's go get that
which way was this Oh openers this is
not the direction of the safe though go
back I must know after all of that I
must know what's in the safe and if you
know it don't spoil it for me
oh of course she's on like she looks
like she might get up from that ones but
Oh My lordy Wow
nine one eight
trying to get in there but he's blocking
it is he gonna come out hey come on
oh she got up I knew it
this guy really not gonna let me in now
did I go too far ahead and this is my
can't go back spot cuz if so Oh No
all right walk away go back and see he's
still there no I don't think I can go
back was it because I can't open that
door man now I'll never know what's in
the safe I gotta start it over wall ding
I can get around the other way right
I'll just have to go all the way around
and go back the other way
wait
I don't think I can actually it's fine
I'll just have to go back again later
unless I hear gunshots over there a
little bit of a fiesta going on over
here she so looks kind of human though I
mean if I didn't just see her eating
that guy's face Oh
sneaking up on me I am at maximum with
the handgun shows another hand grenade
and that's what I really wanted actually
all right well I definitely have no room
for that so
[Music]
that was just a little
I'm gonna get back to with fiery hallway
ones
since he's saw in front of this door
he's still here okay
to keep it moving
there
zoom adore I miss in this Holly
I never mini my free save room
there's the same summer I want to go but
this dude was in the way Oh Oh eggs are
you donut shop the almighty donut shop
I read you definitely tried to knife the
door up the few times and didn't trick
nah-ha oh okay I'm wondering if I
should've waited no no oh I was not
prepared for this not in the slightest
no he's just oh my goodness
my goodness okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
no you know what I'll take this out I'll
take this off if it brings me back for
full life ya seen I'm like I should have
I should have kept the grenade
all right so continue just standing
there menacingly how many times I think
I'll die my guess is a lot Oh
nemesis triggers after I pick up the
hose Oh No the hose was my downfall and
I'm hurting right now
ruff oh wait
oh this checkpoint was a little ways to
go but that's fine because now I know
now I'm a little more prepared Oh Jill
is drunk right now let me heal her okay
I don't want to put that away this time
so ya need to mentally prepare myself
for this
there was something else a oh yeah Oh
everyone's still alive oh no I don't
know the timing of the dodge sometimes
works out sometimes it does I'm probably
just too close to be honest ding I wish
I didn't pick up the hose now I didn't
pick up the hose now I didn't put the
shotgun in the chest nemesis has gotten
me all mind-boggled I know but it's fine
yeah
yeah
I wasn't expecting it to start me this
far back I didn't realize this was my up
here
oh no this is fine everything is fine
nothing to worry about here you guys yes
right away
I had gotten another herb from somewhere
right Dave my memory is not good enough
for this okay sigh one to get the
shotgun still I still need the boat bolt
cutters for sure let me put the hose
here for now cuz clearly I'm not gonna
need it anytime soon in it and I got a
fight
nemesis there was that little corridor
that had the extra shells Wow he's just
right outside
I hate you no stay down
oh oh not they're hungry
they don't Linda where is it I can't
miss it - on top of everything else
it's over there yeah I just wanted to
see I was just curious okay
gather around folks too far ahead of the
group sir all right yeah or a gather
round the campfire oh wait you're in the
way
think I was good enough all right so I
have some extra shells in here
there was also TV blunders
thank you you find I finally dodged
something
well I don't trust myself in a zombie
apocalypse you guys oh I heard him
breathing last second no I'm dead I'm
dead
come on Jill that was so drawn out with
that all right so now I know where it
started me this time I'm gonna drop the
hose off go grab the shotgun I'm gonna
try to corral everyone again so I can
blow them up with that barrel
[Music]
and definitely not gonna be needing that
anytime soon
I'm gonna save my Gurney's also
okay try this again I want to give up
life right now when I do it again no no
no I wanted to go get the shotgun first
which was in here I'm all over the place
be patient with my shots you are super
and I start getting panicky when they
get close
a over here and I got my shotty
yeah
oh I got his arm with that when that
time thanks the barrels
I'm just around this way real quick
Oh
okay hear ye hear ye down the round one
and all right now that I've someone
survives
I hear the feet
well
[Music]
arts preparing for nemesis has the
grenades I've got ten shoddy shots
all right
no time like the now I guess Oh scared
okay alright game pieces on folks
game faces on
dirty noodle Oh
I can't tell if I'm doing damage in them
or if I should just run something tells
me I'm messing up right now
all right you know what
oh no good he's like you ain't going
nowhere like waste this grenade on okay
oh crap
something tells me
all right I'm just gonna run them cuz oh
no wait I don't have the hose so even
though I've made a grave mistake I've
made a grave mistake by leaving the hose
behind I should just restart where did
he go he's gone
alright maybe not there's oh it's fine
it's fine I spent too much time trying
to attack him while he was down no I
don't want a sista game mode let me
learn let me learn from my mistakes yeah
I definitely unloaded a whole clip into
him and he did not dice
so that should have been my first sign
to run oh man I'm so far back alright
it's fine because now that I know that
we should be fine and I should keep the
hose so I can run and put out the fire
obviously I think I have enough mm I
might have enough time I want to get the
bolt cutter so I can get the second
grenade and then I'm just gonna bring
the bolt cutters and put them away
wait such limited okay you know what I'm
not gonna use the shotgun on this I'm
just gonna stun him around I feel like
that's my best option kind of maybe I
don't know you guys think I really need
the shotgun right now the game says I
need help
the game's not wrong but but I believe
in myself it takes me longer than most
to learn certain mechanics
oh I did oh Chando camping all right she
is a still sorry girl
gtfo okay so I have the hose I'm just
gonna need him and run that's it
make sure I got my need out well run
faster than that girl is the fiery
got a hose use it spray it down gtfo we
out fee fie fo was a great game oh we
old
oh my god okay there was 20 dolls on
that stage Wow
all right we're gonna do it again I want
to go to the safe
they got me that last fight we're gonna
hit up the safe this time I have a
better grasp on the dodging I know right
Lex he's so persistent that was fun
though that was fun it was super fun
I'm playing on ps4 right now but you
guys can also get this one Xbox the
reason we're able to snag it early is
because I made an account that's
registered in New Zealand so it was
available in New Zealand already
didn't see this prego after its pre news
for the rest of the game stop and do
what I got you back looks so good this
is level 3 thing she'd legs first
oh yeah that's what's the leg make him
go down and then I can knife him up go
the product page and purchase this game
Suman just not yet I want to try it I'm
curious what's in the safe now it's
probably like a green herb or something
but yeah I created a profile that was
based in New Zealand so I could download
it today otherwise if you don't want to
do that then you just wait until
tomorrow
Victoria we saw this already oh wait I
don't think I can schedule oh there we
go thanks oh right you can't drive
around there was 20 dolls also alright
so I definitely missed some dolls
20 I saw two that were in really obvious
places but 20 tyrant of the deep you
guys don't even know
Joe it's me again top side yet working
on it so what's the plan the old tanks
got me clearing the tracks you might get
in the subway for structure back online
and how do I do that I'll navigate you
to the substation once you copy back
let's do this fast I have never even
restored power
oh I guess the ones I've already shot in
here because there was one right there
so it saves a little bit of my progress
and that's good to know
three moving
dan you've got some strong knees
so shocked that that things at 2:20 I
just want to look everywhere
about that guy
no no from the leg strat it's as good as
it used to be
no stayed what'd I say
they're Brazilian I'll tell you that
Carlos I've reached the main avenue
which way do I go see a big transmission
tower that's the substation you have to
circle around through an LED right
these came by
feel that guys like climbing it and the
steam is pushing up
okay
oh I never came back to the supermarket
I got the bowl okay there so we're not
gonna pick up the hose until the
absolute last thing possible enjoy your
meal
[Music]
it's not all the heels now
something no news coming from you but it
was just gonna powder crap not where
it's not worth good thing I got those
two heels I just need try to brush the
donut shop
yeah buddy
now if there ever really is a zombie
apocalypse and I hope the zombies are
this slow because I'm not a runner got a
bad foot and bad knee let me go ahead
and use one of these
yeah
I was out of there
not picking up the hose I'm not picking
up the hose I don't even need it just
went shotgun hose stay right there on
the ground thank you obviously the needs
and the safe leaving the hose
I don't want it oh yeah that was wack
it's really even dead last two times
actually put a set off which was fun oh
okay let's go up to the safe
what was the eighth code again nine one
eight
oh I meant a nice little bit that will
get you
do I have to do it like an actual hey
thanks for the hacks you guys nice I got
a red dot for my handgun that was
definitely worth it I definitely wish I
had gotten that sooner
yeah I think those three bullets for now
now we get a dot it's literally just
adding a dot nice about it what else
didn't we get it
oh those supermarket all right let's go
back to supermarket I can get that
through here I think
I must know what's in the supermarkets
James Krabs
come on definitely need the herb
definitely need
[Music]
one day I'll figure out the timing hit
or miss alright cool
you didn't get the going in for sure cuz
I didn't know the hose was gonna ruin me
know what's in here
high-grade fan powder for some shoddy
shelves what else
first aid spray let's go
anything else any of their goodies still
stoked about me Oh little dude no bobble
dude I'm gonna forgot I was supposed to
be looking for not probably miss like 10
of them already
look at my my mini Malkin
[Music]
right what else
so anything else I missed the first one
whoa collateral Braniac shells though so
Oh probably
can I get more gunpowder hey Drake I'm
solder there was some gunpowder
somewhere oh yeah
test out my red dot
Oh oh my goodness Oh No let me get these
shoddy Schultz right quick thank you oh
wait no no I did all this just to die in
this stupid corner Oh give me a tea
I need a breather you might get rid of
some stuff
no how about nuts um yummy is my first
English phrase
well I just wanted to use the first aid
spring guys that's what happens I'm
gonna mow well is there some
there we can hear away from your friends
she's stumbling she's a little clumsy
like me tonight
that was a good splatter sting I mean
that guy need but also
where was the other
oops Marnie full health though I don't
know if I'm gonna use that right now hmm
I still didn't picked up the hose oh if
I go pick up the hose then gunpowder
will be spun in the donut shop I know
that uh actually I think it was just
handgun shells that we spawned now that
I think about it oh yeah I didn't go in
here yet
oh I forgot about that guy oh my leg my
leg oh well I'm still fine
it says
oh there's a little guy there we go
nice boom okay is it hose time my leg
yellow see you later Brandon hey come
back tomorrow cuz we're playing dude
it's gonna be sick Oh
[Music]
mom and the truth whoes acquired I got
hoes guys alright for I mean I don't
really need that I need the needs where
was the other goodie I have both of them
now oh I didn't pick it up ash where was
the second Grenada one of the grenades
is in I don't need the bolt-cutters
anymore but the bolt-cutters away well
actually I'll just use this so I can
pick up the spear Nate over here
did this need I really only needed one
need last time to get away
we're gonna get that second one of them
I forgot
it's not right oh it's not here
[Music]
it's okay I think we got just with one
day thank you enough time for me last
night run the only need you got Jill why
is she running so slow nope
[Music]
all right
I got me really good the first time
whoo I love those snows like you could
still see the clear shape of a nose but
it's just all distorted all right
well dolls destroyed nice uh yeah you
guys did too quick playthrough as well
the first one not so quick second one
pretty quick second one definitely less
than half the time of my first but yeah
that is the resident evil 3 resident
evil 3 demo remake demo and it's out
tomorrow in the US if you're in New
Zealand and you have a New Zealand
account you can play today and then of
course resident evil 3 is gonna be out
very very soon
so thank you guys so much for tuning in
and watching thank you for stopping by
and thanks for you know all of you guys
for being so understanding as everyone's
working from home and doing their thing
right now but still trying to bring you
guys the best content that we can so
make sure you're stopping by our website
gamespot.com and you're stopping by our
youtube channel because we still have
content going up every single day along
with our daily live streams tomorrow
we're playing doom eternal so please
come on back it's gonna be fun and I'm
gonna be playing on what's the highest
difficulty not the high ones that make
that mean if you die once you die
forever but you know ultraviolence I'm
gonna be playing on a difficult
difficulty to Mario so please tune in
it's gonna be crazy and fun and gory
just like today kind of was so thank you
guys so much and it's good to see you
all back every day it really means a lot
to us and definitely means a lot to me
so hope see you next time until then
peace out
you